I want to read a quote from that
presentation that you gave on death in
the present moment
as a matter of conscious experience the
reality of your life is always now and I
think that this is a liberating truth
about the nature of the human mind in
fact I think there's probably nothing
more important to understand about your
mind than that if you want to be happy
in this world the past is a memory it's
a thought arising in the present the
future is merely anticipated it is
another thought arising now what we
truly have is this moment and this and
we spend most of our Lives forgetting
this truth refuting it fleeing it
overlooking it and the horror is that we
succeed we manage to never really
connect with the present moment and find
fulfillment there because we are
continually hoping to become happy in
the future and the future never arrives
it is always now however much you feel
you need to plan for the future to
anticipate it to mitigate risks the
reality of your life is now even when we
think we're in the present moment we are
in very subtle ways always looking over
its shoulder anticipating what's coming
next we're always solving a problem and
it's possible to Simply drop your
problem if only for a moment and enjoy
whatever is true of your life in the
present
you say that your mind is all you have
just before that
what does that mean reflecting on that
statement now what what did you hope
that people took away from it
well it's
there's this
we've spoken about it a little bit
already there's this fundamental truth
that you never truly arrive if you're if
your attention is always purposed toward
looking for the next thing anticipating
the next thing
uh if even
in the presence of that very thing that
was the next thing and now it's now you
are busy
telling yourself a story about it you
know you're if your engagement with it
is mediated by thought in each moment
and you can't actually make contact
whether you can't you can't
there's there's this dissatisfaction
even in satisfaction right you get the
thing you were longing for and
you you have such a you're so
distractible you're so you're so
burdened by
this automaticity of thought this
conversation you're having with yourself
that
the present moment it isn't even Salient
enough to you right and so it's it's a
um
most of us most of the time live in that
kind of you know we get buffeted between
the past and anticipating the future and
thinking about the past and that flicker
happens over even the present moment
right I mean we're just we're just you
know like I mean even in a conversation
like this like I'm saying something if
part of my attention is women have I
gone on too long about this or like it
like did that even make sense what was
it there's part of me that is that is
potentially talking to myself about the
very conversation we're having now now
that is all too normal everyone is in
that position I mean people are people
who are listening to us now are
struggling to follow my train of thought
as I speak one because I'm long-winded
but two it's my speech is competing with
speech that there is is occurring to
them in their head right they're saying
what's he talking about oh Jordan didn't
say that what is he where does he get
off talking about Jordan now and there's
someone in their [__] head who seems
to be them but strangely not them
because if they're the one talking and
also listening why are they having that
conversation in the first place right
this is this
people are looking over their own
shoulder into the even when they're
trying to seize the present with both
hands right even if they take my advice
in that quote and say okay I got to be
all about that now right
the future never arrives there's just
now so let's enjoy the now what they
will find is they lack the tools to
really do that and so one tool
again is something something like
psychedelics right you take the
requisite dose of LSD or psilocybin or
MDMA again these are potentially very
different experiences but they're
they're what will happen under the Aegis
of any of those compounds is
very likely you will have a full
collision with the present moment of A
Sort that you have never had before if
it's your first time on one of those
drugs and all of a sudden the the your
sensory experience and your concept even
your conceptual experience will begin to
unfold and you will realize there is
just much more here than I than you
realize right like it's like everything
becomes
a kind of miracle and
the problem with that is that
finding meaning in everything
is crazy right you become the guy who's
just like like you know if I'm staring
at this microphone I'm so I come here
stoned and I'm just like oh my God that
microphone is just that you know that's
not the guy you want on your podcast
right so
but it is possible it
the
it is possible to to fall into The Well
of being such that the present Mo the
present moment lacks for nothing right
you're just you recognize that love what
you meet what you really mean by love
what you should mean by love is not this
transactional thing that you get going
with a specific person because of your
shared history together and because of
their qualities that you happen to like
um it is actually a state of being that
you can just plunge into and you
recognize that this is
the the point of life is to is to
recognize this more and more right and
so and love is one facet to the to this
Jewel compassion is another just
just awe you know is is another I mean
it gets different shadings depending on
the environment you put it in I mean
it's like if you're in the presence of
of human or animal suffering well then
compassion is the thing that gets
Amplified
but in the sign in in real silence and
in in a real
undistracted collision with the present
moment when you don't have this voice in
your head diverting you uh or coming up
from behind seeming to be you right like
but what happens is
people feel like a
a separate self I mean here perhaps I
should rewind for a second this here's
the here's the starting point for 99.9
percent of humanity people feel like a
self people feel like they're they're a
subject
in the middle of their experience right
they feel like they're having an
experience they feel like they're
they're on the edge of experience in
some sense they don't feel like they
don't feel identical to experience right
so I'm so and experience is you know
your five sensory channels and your mind
right so you've got you're seeing
hearing smelling tasting touching
thinking feeling emotions
and you've got this whole
cacophony of what it's like to be you in
each moment and sometimes it's very very
pleasant and sometimes sometimes it's
very unpleasant and sometimes it's just
you know
uh
normal and there's nothing really
especially Salient about it
um and the default sense is
to feel like a self in the middle of
that right and
it's that
it's that starting point that is
actually the basis for all of our
dissatisfaction and psychological
suffering I mean that is the that is the
knot that has to be untied
to that that really allows for a
recognition of what the mind is like
prior to identification with thought and
prior to
this fee this this capture by this this
automatic this reflexive seeking and not
finding operation that we're we're
constantly engaged with so
um
yeah it's possible to so yes
on some level you know certainly
spiritually speaking now is everything
there really is just Consciousness in
his contents in each moment right and
and there's there's never a reason to
wait to recognize that right
um this isn't to disavow all the other
projects we could have in human life
that take some time to accomplish right
I'm not saying you everyone should just
become a monk or go to a cave and starve
I mean like there are things that I like
to do in the world and want to get done
and I have projects but in each moment
the question is what is available to
attention
uh and why do you suffer right and if
you if you
if you're going to ask yourself why do
you suffer in each moment why why is
this moment just a little crappy right
why is it just not good enough why am I
looking forward to this thing in an hour
and I'm unable to locate a real ease of
being now you know before this good
thing happens
um before this uncertainty gets resolved
right before I hear from the doctor that
I don't have the thing that I'm worried
about what do you like all of these
contingencies
what's available now what you find is
and you know meditation is the ultimate
answer to this in my view
you find is this this on the on the part
of virtually everyone this basic
incapacity to break the spell of
identification with thought and just
rest attention
as Consciousness in the present moment
and meditation is simply the act of
doing that ultimately and there are many
techniques that that can seem like
something other in the beginning but
ultimately if it works
meditation is the ability to to look at
this thing you thought was your ego
whether you thought was yourself that
you thought was the homunculus that was
in the middle of your experience
and not find it and not find it in a way
that actually relieves you of the
problem of egocentricity for that moment
right it might only last in the
beginning
it might only last a moment right and
then you'll be lost in thought again but
that but the question is once you learn
to meditate
the question is always what do you do
next and if you don't know how to
meditate well you're just going to
helplessly be thinking that thought and
you'll think it for as long as you'll
think it and it'll you know make you
angry or sad or regretful or whatever
depending on its contents and then
you'll try to have to figure out how to
rearrange your life on the basis of that
thought so it's to not be angry or sad
or regretful but when once you know how
to meditate you can recognize thoughts
as thoughts and they just arise and
disappear in this wider space of
awareness and you locate your well-being
in that space as as that space
but but if all of that sounds like
religious gibberish that is of totally
interested in
and it would have seemed that way to me
when I was 18 the only thing for a
hard-headed skeptic uh much of the time
is an experience that snaps you out of
your egocentric Illusions for some
period of time and so for me Peru goes
to Peru go to Peru or um um I which I
haven't done I haven't done Ayahuasca
but for me psychedelics weren't they
they were indispensable because
I was someone it had you
confronted me as an undergraduate in
college with whatever I just said
I would have even if I had been
convinced to try meditating for an hour
I wouldn't have had the aptitude for it
that such that I would have immediately
noticed there was there was there there
I would have I would have bounced off I
would have got the sense that
it didn't work for me like I you know
most people
you know someone like someone like
Richard Dawkins is a perfect example
it's like I I am bushed him on my
podcast with you know five minutes of
meditation and I thought you're gonna
say spiked the drink with yeah he no
Richard I told Richard he should he
should do psychedelics
um
but
most people who are especially and this
is especially true of hard-headed
rationalist skeptic scientist types
um
they're so enamored of thought thought
is the only appendage they have ever
found by which to or by which to
interface with reality such that they
can't imagine a mind prior to thought
they can't imagine a non-conceptual
engagement with reality that reveals
anything you know it sounds like what do
you it sounds like brain damage right
like my concepts are great like you
should have Concepts as good as my
Concepts right why what are you you're
going to hit me on the head with a
hammer yeah then I'll have fewer
Concepts right but
so when you point them inward when you
say okay just just notice that like just
try try to focus on your breath for 10
seconds and notice how hard that is
notice what happens notice that you get
carried away by something that you are
not authoring right like you're did you
decide to get distracted about what's
going to happen for lunch uh when I just
told you to pay attention to your breath
and you were on it for two seconds and
now you're thinking about lunch at like
does that does that no is that at all
interesting to you that that's the
hardest thing in the world
to just pay attention to anything
some people find that interesting some
people find that that's a there's a sort
of an intimation of a path there like
okay maybe there's something to discover
here that could provide some relief to
something that is in fact ailing me but
for many people not and then if you give
those people
some psychedelic experience
many of them recognize oh okay there is
a there I don't know how I don't know if
this one is optimal this is just this is
just different
but it's so different
and some of it is so pleasant and some
of it is so
undermining of the [__] that I
generally find so captivating
that this is a Counterpoint to how I've
been living my life right and so I need
I need to I need more tools and that's
how many of us have got into meditation
in other news this episode is sponsored
by betterhelp that might be something
interfering with your happiness or
preventing you from achieving your goals
it is unbelievably helpful to have
someone professionally trained who can
help you get through whatever you're
facing the service is available for
clients worldwide you can log into your
account at any time and send a message
to your therapist they'll give you
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you don't even have to leave
the house it is a quicker cheaper and
more convenient way to start doing
therapy and you do not know just how
good the texture of your own mind could
be if you started working with someone
professionally trained who can help you
get through whatever you're facing you
can switch therapists for free if it
doesn't work out for any reason and
there is no additional charge head to
better
help.com modern wisdom to get 10 off
your first month of therapy that's
betterhelp.com
modern wisdom